this is a production of Cornell
University all right well thank you for
the introduction Justine it's great to
be here um it's been a long time I've
been to New York a number of times but
I'm so used to being a Geneva with a lot
of the events uh that have been held
over the years so it's nice to be here
in itha um and to share some of my
research projects or research project
with you and when uh Justine reached out
to me earlier this year uh it was to
specifically talk about some of my crop
load research and so this is a
challenging thing to do in a typical
4550 minute uh seminar but I hope I do a
good job of explaining kind of the path
that we went on in Oregon over the last
10 years and so this is really um
talking about um an integrated research
and extension project that I did with
the industry there and actually I'm
still doing there and so um just the lay
of the land from for Oregon so this is
the state of Oregon the black area there
on the west side is the wamit valley so
how many of you have heard of the wamit
valley all right great everybody knows
and what do we grow in the wamit valley
or most of Oregon panor so raspber
raspberry yes raspberries blackberries
blueberries where small fruit and
definitely a great uh State nurseries
actually nurseries is our number one AG
cultural output for the state of Oregon
so the L Valley the star there is where
I'm located I'm uh in Coralis on the
main campus um I have a Statewide
extension role but I also do research
and teaching as Justine mentioned um we
do not have any other Extension agent
that serves the wamit valley yet it's
the 69% of the total State acreage um so
I end up doing dual roles as kind of a
regional extension person as well as a
Statewide uh person and our climate in
that area is a cool climate so it's cool
climate Mediterranean so we have uh we
get about a thousand millimeters of rain
a year so 40 to 42 inches of rain per
year during the summer it is drier so
our growing season is much drier than
what you would appreciate here in in
Upstate New York um but our uh we don't
get very cold we don't freeze and we are
we usually are hovering around 2100 heat
units for our GR season so this gives
you an idea of the growing season from
April 1 to October 31st if you look at
the long term uh you could see that the
um about 2100 heat units and that's in
Fahrenheit and when we look at the more
recent years we we're getting warmer
we're getting closer to that 24 2600
heat units during the active growing
season but we're not getting drier
necessarily the averages we see there
for the precipitation during the active
growing season are about the same so so
it just depends on the year we have a
lot more variability some years are
drier than others um and so we are cool
climate viticulture we grow cool climate
varieties our top three varieties that
we grow across the state are P Noir
penree and Chardonnay and th those are
our top three because they originated in
that cool climate region where we grow
most of the wine grapes in the state now
with premium wine production in a cool
climate almost every grower knows that
they have to do one thing and it seems
Universal across any premium wine
growing region especially a cool climate
one is that they have to do crop
restrictions so crop thinning and it's a
strong belief that they have to do that
or they will not ripen their Fruit by
the time the winter or the the fall
rains come and they want to be able to
hasten ripening so here I pulled the
yield data that's been reported into our
state and this happens to be a national
egg statistics data from 1990 to 2010
for these three varieties and P Noir is
in orange charday and green and P green
purple and one of the things you can see
here is that the let's see if this will
show up
you um basically there is a very narrow
range so if you look at that uh at the Y
AIS the amount of yield is pretty low so
between 1 and a half and three tons per
acre for most of them now if you follow
the plot to about 1998 you'll see that
penree and penor follow at about the
same exact tons per acre now once you go
past 1998 you see a separation they're
starting to thin the P Noir consistently
at about the same levels that they
always had but now the whites they're
allowing to crop a little bit higher not
drastically higher but a little bit
higher and if you look over this window
this orange shadow box there that's
showing over that 20 here period that
they basically were cropping P Noir very
consistently over time and you can see
here's the averages during this window
of time Pano is 2.1 tons per acre
chardet 2.6 P gree 2.5 but the
interesting thing is just taking a
viticultural perspective and looking at
these State data is that between
1990 and probably the early 2000s the
plantings that went in were higher
density meaning more plants per acre
and so there's at least so the being
very conservative you'd say there's 35%
more plants per acre probably more so
like 50% more plants per acre yet we're
not seeing an increase in yields we're
seeing a de basically a stay stagnant
yield Target during that time doesn't
make sense you have more plants per acre
your tons per acre should go up unless
you're doing more cluster thinning which
was the case and when we looked at uh
when I started around 2007 at Oregon
State University I was noticing how much
crop was going on to the ground did not
make any sense because not only were
they cutting off crop they were planting
new vineyard Acres because they said
they didn't have enough P Noir and I'm
thinking well 40% of your P NOS on the
vineyard floor but I was the new kid on
the Block then I didn't want to stick my
neck out too much I just observed and
looked at what was going on around
me and so I wanted to collect data is
any good extension person they always
tell us we have to do needs assessments
and needs assessment in my case was not
just going and surveying everybody it
was looking observing for several years
before I came out with a targeted survey
of the industry about what things
puzzled me and I couldn't address a
question unless I knew what I was
dealing with so I I did an industry
survey in 20 uh in
2012 and basically asked what are your
crop management practices so yield
management practices and what we found
was that overwhelmingly 82% of the
industry who answered the survey did
cluster thinning and it wasn't just for
pan Noir they spent the most time
cluster thinning P Noir which showed in
the state reports and the interesting
thing was that they spent most time
cluster thinning pan Noir because it's
the most costly or it's the most they
can bring in the most value so highest
price per ton because of where it ends
up their highest price bottles of wine
and so at time
67% of the those who said they C cropped
in said they had the same exact target
it was between two and 2.75 tons per
acre so that difference is really from
the the luxury premium Brands would say
they were closer to two and the more um
um higher production the value Brands
were at 2.75 so that's not a very big
span and it was very expensive to do
cluster thinning about 40 hours per acre
to send a labor crew either one or three
passes they were doing multiple passes
and that in today's dollars is anywhere
from $700 to $800 per acre so that
varies obviously with the number of
plants per acre so we published this
study uh in uh Journal of extension and
that was the framework for just setting
out to do the work that we did over the
next few years and when I did that
survey I asked well why do you crop then
the overwhelming responses for Quality
now it might have came in a different U
package they might have said well it's
to hasten ripening or it's to increase
flavors or it's to increase
concentration which all get to Quality
only 7% said they did it for rot reasons
so they wanted to prevent overlapping
clusters for rot um and then as rot
prevention and 11% said for Vine balance
but they were also saying oh in addition
to doing this for crop quality reasons
so nobody at that time identified what
exactly yield management or what Vine
balance was so I wanted to address that
and to have them look more at what is
the vine balance really and is that more
important than just a yield Target so we
set out to evaluate this now in the
literature for Oregon some prior people
including uh Marcus cleever from he was
a Emeritus professor at UC Davis at the
time but he moved Oregon and started
doing his own research there just on his
own farm and he and some Growers
identified that for Oregon our crop load
which is or otherwise known as the RAS
index which is the yield divided by
pruning weight should be 3 to six
whereas California is oftentimes cited
as having a Ras index of five to 10 so
that's looking at that vegetative growth
at your printing weight and your yield
and looking at those
comparatively so in this case of course
in viticulture World yield does not
equal crop load you have to evaluate the
canopy size relative to the fruit weight
which we can do with our pruning
weights so I started my first uh crop
load trials as any researcher would with
small smaller scale studies I decided to
start them out in two different areas of
the state that are penon Noir producing
regions so although the wamit valley
produces the most P Noir Southern Oregon
although it likes to be known for other
things is actually still the number one
variety growing there is still pan Noir
it's just a warmer region and more Aid
so we put in a timing by intense trial
at two commercial Vineyards during three
years so 2010 through
2013 um actually most of them started in
2011 but the first trial started in 2010
so we evaluated this in those two
Vineyards and basically when we
addressed this question with uh multiple
regressions analysis which one made more
difference canopy size or fruit yield to
influence bricks
phta uh toal anthos and phenolics uh and
Yan we found that overwhelmingly it was
the printing weight the vine Vigor the
vine size probably the vineyard had more
to do with that than
doing uh CR crop binning so yields yes
it did influence bricks that's what
everybody uh hopes to achieve when they
cropped in is to have more sugar uh with
time and then it increased total
anthocyanins those are the two things
that change the most in this trial but
we took it a little bit further uh when
we did this trial because we were
comparing different cluster thinning
practices what we found was that if they
went lower than one cluster per shoot
there was absolutely no gain so there
would be no point to physically Mo
remove any more clusters regardless of
what the tons per acre were and in some
years that one cluster per Shute was
well over two and a half tons per acre
and so that was very interesting to come
up with the trial and we didn't just
stop at the vineyard we took it to Wine
production uh my colleague Michael Chen
ran some Aroma chemist chemistry on this
these plots are from just the control
which be not thinned and then the
thinned treatments from these two
commercial wineries uh in 2011 and 2012
actually this one is not from the
Southern Oregon site it's from the wamit
Valley site and you can see there's
virtually no difference in and so these
are odor activity values from a GCO and
so between those two years very
different years very different crop
levels you can see seven .3 tons per
acre and 2.6 to 4.3 tons per acre no
difference in the odor activity values
of these of of these win so we shared
this information with Growers and they
were very much um they thought it was
interesting Growers liked it better than
wine makers but basically they were uh
not convinced and one of the things I
tried to point out is well maybe there's
no differences not because we didn't
look at the right site or that we didn't
look at at the right thing it was
because we don't have a wide enough
range of yields and we kind of knew that
going in um we had there's there was no
relationship like this one here which is
um a very commonly cited paper of by
caver and dzan where they looked at
different crop load metrics and this
just showed this was actually Cabernet
San where they had it on six different
Training Systems two different root
stocks and they were looking at okay if
you increase your Leaf area to crop
weight you're going to increase your
sugars because physiologically you have
more Leaf area to support the ripeness
we were hoping to see this all we saw
was a cloud of points and our values
were about fourfold greater than this in
terms of our square meters of canopy to
kilograms of fruit so we clearly were at
a whole different level because our crop
levels are so low and our canopy size is
so big that none of this made sense we
were not overcrowed cing our Vines at
least physiologically so this was out of
the question we weren't seeing any sort
of relationship like
this um we did a Time course study
because the logic would be if we need to
crop thin doing it earlier would make
sense to maybe sequester any benefit of
having a reduced crop earlier and what
we found is that crop thinning too early
in vigorous Vines was not good they
basically were more araceous there was
no benefit to doing that so we really
found more differences in the intensity
of crop thinning rather than the timing
so Growers at the time were doing all of
their crop thinning at leg face so right
before Veron and so we said after this
okay there's no point to do your crop
thinning earlier because there was no
benefit it was actually holding back
some of the Vigor and creating a better
quality uh from the fruit and wine
perspective and then when we did the
wine sensory there was no difference in
most of the situations other than that
earliest time point the earliest and
most severe the wines were herbaceous so
we did not want to to go that row so we
did this work we shared the results we
even let Growers do some of the tastings
and they were like you know this is
really great um and but you know this is
only providing an answer for those two
Vineyards in those vintages we don't
think this is what you're seeing
everywhere else so I said okay well I
recognize this even before I was done
with that first set of Trials and so I
recognized that a lot of people have
done crop thinning research crop load
research and there's still a strong
resistance to trying to increase yields
and so I recognized that there was no
way that we could understand what would
happen unless we brought in more Growers
and actually had them do the project
with us in a way that they produce
larger scale wines because we made the
wines at the University and they always
say well you know research wines don't
taste like U commercial wines and so so
you know they you guys aren't wine
makers I said fair enough you want to
help out with this then then let's do it
and so this is how we came up with
what's known as the Statewide crop load
project and we had planned this out for
about two years prior to starting in
2012 and we brought a group of Growers
together and said will this work let's
Design This Together and the goal of
this trial was to not just do research
like we always do research and we just
send our students and lab staff out to a
site to collect data we are going to
train the industry to do this themselves
in the in a block of their choosing
where they can test the different crop
levels that they wanted to so number one
was engage industry in that research
project process and actually give them
protocols have them follow through and I
thought in at least we they'll learn and
observe and then we'll also get a big
robust data set that we can work with so
that we could do number two which was to
understand how yields between a
long-term period and different climates
even within the region and the different
sites what does it look like in terms of
the yield response by doing crop
thinning and then number three was to
hopefully after these 10 years get
enough data to support developing some
true guidelines that aren't just saying
oh well we think it's two to two and a
half tons per acre for p Noir to
actually have some guidelines or
thresholds and then fourth is a more
recent uh development is that now we're
trying to forecast use this data set to
forecast yield into the future with
climate
change and so we started out the project
in 2012 and we wrapped it up after the
10th growing season in 2021 and this
this the names of all the Vineyards that
were involved in the project so we had
25 companies across 28 Vineyards that's
because some of them did it in more than
one Vineyard site that they own and
operate and it was done across five
counties all within the wamit valley and
that covered six avas so even though the
wamit valley is a big Ava there's other
avas within it so that's why um we were
across all of those uh areas and you can
see that between there were 10 to 15
Vineyards in the project any one year
and we asked that some uh companies were
in a minimum of three years we
recognized they couldn't commit to more
than three years but some did there were
five that were in it for all 10 years so
that was really great to see uh and most
of them were in for uh four 14 of them
were in three or more years so we
designed this in a way that would be
doable for Growers you know cluster
thinning is pretty easy it's not like
doing spray trials where where there
could be leakage or you know mistakes I
mean there can be mistakes and cluster
thinning but this was pretty easy it's a
onetime point organize yourself and get
it done and we did it as a randomized
complete block design in each Vineyard
so I would go and help The Growers flag
off or um learn how to set this up and
within it we had these black areas which
are where their data collection points
so that they could collect data and they
weren't worried about collecting it
across you know a 600 foot span of area
but they applied the treatments by
telling their thinning crew to go
through and thin on a on a pattern basis
because we recognize doing Target yields
is too hard it's easier to just tell the
crews to do a certain clusters per shoot
these are the different treatments so
between a half cluster which is one Z
one0 to no thinning at all and so so
most grow uh most collaborators in the
project chose to do either two clusters
in no thinning and one cluster per shoot
some of them if they did more than that
often would do this one two one two or
one and a half clusters per shoot and so
they replicated it much more than three
times per their Vineyard site they
usually had at least five reps but we
had them collect data on a minimum of
three because they just they realized
how long it takes to collect data now to
any field researcher you know how much
time that takes there's didn't take that
long but they're doing this on top of
managing and producing a crop so we had
them do this throughout the year and
they collected data we paired it down to
only what we would use we didn't have
them do extra stuff because they didn't
have time so we had them do fruitfulness
in Spring and that was something new for
all of them and they learned the power
of that when they moved on at leg phase
that's when we they did cluster thinning
and they had to do pre and post counts
everas on we had them do uh tissue
samples
so we sent those off to a lab where they
could an be analyzed for macro and
micronutrients and we only did that for
two crop levels just so that if a
company had say five or six crop levels
they weren't paying for extra uh costs
there so the Growers picked up the cost
for the first five years the second five
years that was donated by uh Fruit
Growers lab in California so that saved
a lot of money and of course at harvest
the first five years um they would they
would Harvest they' get their samples
ready we would would run and pick up the
samples from them they would get yield
data of course fruit samples in the
first five years were sent to ETS labs
they did all of them and then the second
five years I took that
inhouse um and then in the winter we
would get dormant pruning weights we
also have phology reports by all of the
Growers and wine production notes and we
also collected some air temperature data
in all of these Vineyards so this is a
looks like a like a paired down method
for research but for Growers this was a
lot and they you know that was a lot for
them to manage and so we had some
producers that couldn't stay in the
trial because they just didn't have
enough manpower but everybody else who
could you know designate this to
somebody and their staff they followed
through which was really impressive so
results so what did we find well this
just shows the yields the means and the
standard deviations of the yields over
time just basically showing and this is
across all crop thinning treatments we
had a 10-year mean of just under
one pound per foot so that was the mean
and if we look at the different years we
had some high yielding years 15 17 and
18 which really were great to see but we
expected that we would have some low
cropping years like 2012 and 2020 where
they couldn't you know they basically
said we don't even need to crop in
almost but you know they had to stay the
course they had to crop in the same
plots the same way every
year and then most of our crop variation
had to do with cluster weight and a lot
of that was driven by whether we had
rain or cool weather at Bloom because we
do tend to have rain up until about
Fourth of July and so this is what what
made a good year was a dry Bloom what
was a poor year a wet Bloom so it vastly
affected cluster
weights and then fruitfulness was pretty
uh pretty much the same throughout all
the years there's some variability there
but we usually are not over two clusters
per shoot usually 1.8 that's the highest
we had during during the the time of the
study so that gives you a sense for if
you're doing it on a thinning regime
what kind of crop level we're dealing
with
there now this is the actual uh yield in
pounds per linear foot and I do all of
this in pounds per linear foot because
most of the time I'm sharing this with
Growers who I'm trying to help them
convert to going away from tons to
pounds per a linear foot and this is
what's here is just on the on the x-
axis is the different cluster thinning
treatments and then the yield on the Y
AIS
so this is the no thinning and you can
see the variability in these colored
bars are by year so the variability in
any given year on the amount of yield
that we have and then when we have so
the range in yield was from 7 to 1.8
that's the for no thinning and then this
is the percent reduction in crop level
for each one of those clusters pursu
treatments so then I'm starting with
this to show that okay there is a a a
significant magn itude of changing the
crop level so that when we look at the
data you can see what what how the how
the results are and then the average for
a full crop was between one one and 1.2
pounds per linear foot still not a very
high yield in terms of the one great
production
world but we did reduce it so this is
the best way for me to to summarize the
result of analyzing each one of The
Vineyards and each one of their results
over time was just to put a tally for if
there was a significant uh Anova that
came from doing this on the different
trial sites so this plot shows the tally
of number of Vineyards that have an
impact on say total soluble solids or pH
or titratable acidity in those Vineyards
now keep in mind every year we have
between 10 and 14 sites but you can see
in any one of the years the max we had
was five sites having a difference
in their bricks when we did cluster
thinning and so there are some Vineyards
that had no effect at all so 42 to 85%
of the sites had something different if
they cluster thin in Fruit chemistry
wise but then there's some that had
absolutely no effect depending on the
year the fruit came out is not
statistically different and between six
and 25% of the sites there was no
difference in their primary ripeness so
the things that they use to measure at
Harvest so bricks PHT
and the most common differences were in
PH and anos sinus and you can see it was
always a fraction of the total we never
had a consistent response over time that
say this Vineyard always responded in a
certain way to Cluster thinning or to
any parameter so one year it might have
been different in antoin but the next it
wasn't so very inconsistent results
which were usually no results at all so
that was a lot of The Growers would see
but but the mean looks different but the
error bars they overlap so there's no
difference really statistically so then
we looked at crop load our crop loads
are not high here's a span it's like
basically less than one and up to almost
seven and I want to point out here 2018
is the year where we had higher crop
loads it was a dry season our canopies
did not grow as big but it also had good
fruit set so we had smaller canopy
relative to the amount of crop but it
was one of the ones where we had had
very few differences in Fruit
composition in any site now 2021 this is
mid-range crop load and had almost the
lowest amount of differences so there's
not a relationship of oh we have super
high crop loads or super low we're
seeing very basically we're pretty low
that we're not over cropping at our
level and so people were wondering well
why don't we see more differences uh and
part of it is is because of how we how
this project is done it's all in pinoir
Vineyards that are cane pruned and they
all do shoot thinning and so when I look
at their shoot density data they're all
consistently three to four shoots per
linear foot so they did their job in
shoot thinning and so they're not spur
pruning and leaving 10 10 shoots per
linear foot so that's why we're in a
pretty narrow range and it just led me
to believe well if you go any further
cluster removal there's really no point
because you've already done your first
thinning by your shoot thinning and so
it's trying to get Growers to understand
that when we work through why there are
so few differences in these
Vineyards now this is what are my one of
my I didn't show a lot of these plots
because this gets very confusing we're
at the stage where we're taking all of
the years all of The Vineyards together
and analyzing them to come up with some
models which require mixed modeling
mixed models and you know basically
keeping everything fixed like year fixed
uh yield fixed but then we use the site
as random in the model and we've come up
with this just the yield to to Total
soluble solids and basically from this
we came up with that for every 1
kilogram per meter of cluster thinning
so that would be 67 pounds per linear
foot that you decrease your crop level
you'll
gain2 in Brick
and when I shared this with Growers
there was an aha moment with one of the
Growers which was brilliant I was glad
he noticed it because I think most
wouldn't he's like well we don't crop
thin that much we're not reducing it by
67 pounds per line your foot or more you
know more than one pound pound per or
one kilogram per meter so that is you
know basically the slope is very shallow
and we're not seeing this response
unless we're in a year or a Vineyard
where we're in very high crop levels and
for uh single canopy can pruned and
shoot thin fet in Noir you're not going
to be above probably about two pounds
per linear
foot but what can we learn when we do
have these years where we have a bumper
uh crop and so that's what I've done
recently and and here I'm showing 2015
2015 was a warm season a high yield
season this is just all Vineyards that
were involved in that year were 13
different Vineyards you can see the span
of yield there and certain Vineyards are
very low yielding and some are pretty
high and the span there is showing the
the the cluster thinning results and so
only four Vineyards in that year had a
significant annova that came out that
said okay your crop thinning led to
differences in bricks and why do I focus
on bricks because that's what their
contracts are written on whether we can
quibble about whether bricks are
important but in the business business
world it's yield targets it's bricks
those are the two most common things
written in contrast so basically what
can we learn in these years do they in a
high crop year and um these are the four
Vineyards that had a significant
response you know there's a higher
higher amount of yield that they had but
we're going to look at that a little bit
closer so four of those Vineyards are
plotted here in the blue and you can see
the span of their yield and their total
soluable solids uh and there is a
significant
relationship and when we look at
applying this model to what Growers
would care about and they say well what
yield would I need to reach 23 bricks
because that's a lot of times 229 or 23
is what's in their contracts well they
could achieve that at 1.7 pounds per
linear foot they didn't have to go to 08
so when we started the study most
Growers were going to about 0.8.7 pounds
per linear foot of course they would get
riper if you want to use this model if
they did that but it's not necessary and
all those other Vineyards that didn't
have a significant Anova response
they're the ones in Orange it didn't
matter whether they crop thinder or not
they're bricks was not you know it's
basically a flat
line and the next thing would be okay so
if your bricks are higher your PHS are
probably going to have similar
relationship not necessarily we often
saw saw this it was just a cloud so some
Growers would say well we're gonna you
know as the climate gets warmer we're
going to hang more fruit it'll preserve
acids not necessarily because our our pH
didn't always follow this yield
relationship now case there are a few
cases where crop thinning had more
impact and these tended to be in
highdensity Vineyard so I mentioned that
over time there was a a more Vineyards
planted at high density now this picture
here is of a vineyard with a meter
between Vines and a meter and a half
between or between rows now this is
developed by Californians who didn't
anticipate the amount of vigor we have
and this is a picture when it's at about
you know little past solar noon and the
vines are relatively recently hedged but
if you I came in at 9 or 10 o'clock in
the morning they would be shading this
next canopy pretty significantly because
they're just the Hedge height we have
you know you're not hedging immediately
you can't constantly hedge so we
oftentimes will see shading into the
canopy of these these Vines and that's
what we saw with these highdensity
Vineyards is that there was a
significant response of crop thinning
probably because they didn't have as
much active canopy that was fully
exposed to sunlight as much during the
day so this is that same Vineyard you
just saw and this is in 2015 and we
found that the the commercially
acceptable kind of contract basis fell
at about that 1.6 1.7 pounds per linear
foot but if they cropped in they
continued to have a higher amount of
bricks in that fruit of course be to a
point where You' suggest desiccation
when you're at 25 bricks but they
basically saw a benefit there was no uh
flat lining there and we found the same
to be true in another Vineyard this is
slightly wider spacing 6x for and they
have that similar response but they this
vineyard's very interesting because
their range is went from 17 to 24 bricks
and by thinning in this heavy cop year
and they're they reached the
commercially viable one at 1.0 the
interesting thing about this Vineyard is
that it is a cooler site it actually
should be warmer and we were puzzled by
this all the time and what happened is
this is a much larger production site
more value production we found they
weren't applying fungicides as late into
the season as they probably should have
their canopies looked okay but they had
powdery mildew so the fruit was fine but
now the fruit the canopy wasn't as
photosynthetically active when it has
powdery mildew so they had to have more
crop thinning to be able to make it to
that commercial ripeness so all of this
plays into kind of not having a good
setting for a high density Vineyard at
least if you want practical management
of quality fruit just means more
management of reducing crop
level so from this project you know you
I just showed some case examples from
certain High crop years but in most
cases we really had very little effect
of croping because we were already doing
some of it by our shoot thinning
practices what we found was there was no
decline in Vine Health we monitored
macro and micronutrients it was very
dull absolutely no statistical
difference in anything in any year there
is no consistent impact on fruit
composition and there was Vineyard sites
were really what was different not so
much the crop
thinning we made wines and we found that
the yield did not affect characteristics
so we went straight to sensory uh and
there was very little difference in
Aroma color mouth feel and when we did
some isolated years and did um some GC
GC Mass specb we found no consistent
patterns just like what we found in our
basic chemistry work too so not very
exciting but that also was very telling
because we did it so many years and so
consistently in these Vineyards we did a
Consumer Panel in the beginning no
differences by the consumer but we went
away from consumer panels because we
recognized that it wasn't consumers who
told told people how to crop in it was
wine makers it was the it was wine
makers telling Growers they had to crop
in so we said well we need a wine maker
panel because they're going to taste
wines and they're going to make a
decision and what we found from the wine
maker panel they all had p p Noir wine
makers in the wama Valley and they found
no difference by crop level uh there was
no preferred crop level and there were
only differences by site and vintage and
this really did not sit well with them
they didn't like the fact that there
wasn't any difference and when they had
the sensory trials we did them in black
glasses they didn't like that either so
that was toask any color differences but
they we also did do it with clear
glasses so there weren't as many
differences
and the next step that we did was the
in-house uh sensory that was basically
took it from OSU doing the TR the the
panels and the in-house because they
didn't like the results they were
getting and they thought that there
should be differences now with they do
in-house sensory they know there's going
to be a difference right because they
know they're tasting the trial but they
had to taste them blind and we had a
protocol we had a protocol for
everything and when they tasted them
blind there was no clear preference they
had really positive remarks about all
the wines but the exercise of revealing
what they were then they changed their
story they became conservative they're
like well okay maybe we don't like the
heaviest crop and we don't like the
lowest crop but the middle is just about
right it's the Goldilocks so they would
identify a preference which I can
understand you're still trying to break
that barrier but they will have things
like lovely lines for all of them and
then all of a sudden once they know the
identity they're like well we can't
possibly like that one um and I should
say the in-house sensory we still have
not gotten all the data back and so they
want to hold on to it they're learning
something from it but they want to hold
on to it so the next step was okay we
did all of this stuff but we had all
this extra line so we decided Well let's
do some sensory Outreach but collect
data at the same time so right before
the pandemic in December 2019 we did a
technical wine tasting event 72 wines
four vintages 12 companies they were all
blind it took us about a month to set
this up and we it was an open invitation
to Industry I didn't want the public
there I wanted industry there and I
didn't care if they were from The
Vineyard or the winery they just had to
have an interest but we did Target early
to mid career wine makers I wanted to
make sure they were in the room because
too often you know wine maker who is
learning something new is always told
what to do about the next person up or
next person in command and so we
recognize that if we can influence these
younger wi makers they can take it
forward as they Advance through their
career so that's what I think it worked
and so just going to give you a little
bit of example from this technical
tasting we had this Vineyard uh this
vintage 2015 which was the big vintage
this company had chose to thin to
certain certain cropping levels so they
they were you know 2.55 to
3.79 we asked the panelists as they went
through to rank rank uh concentration
and preference and then guess which one
was the lowest or highest crop and so
this one was the
2.55 uh tons per acre was the most
concentrated it was the most preferred
and it was in fact the lowest yield and
the interesting thing from the next
vintage6
where the slightly higher
yields the 3.15 tons per acre was the
most concentrated and guessed as the
lowest yield so it's it's not clear from
what they normally look at and in most
cases you know there they found this
when they tasted all those other 72
wines there it was really tough to tell
any difference between the crop levels
so we had a reveal at the end and we
talked about the results and so it was a
very important Learning lesson for
people who attended that I think really
took away a lot uh they took a lot away
from it especially if they weren't
people that were involved in the project
so they got to see it uh at the end
there and so the question was how you
know we've got all this data how can we
determine impact in adoption we're
always told to do this as academics and
especially if we have extension
appointments and are we transforming
yield management practices in or well at
the outset of this project I had
designed a couple different steps at the
at the outset I did the industry uh
survey then I wanted to survey the
collaborators who are most involved in
this project and then resurvey the
Oregon industry so we're actually doing
some of this now we did some at the
midpoint around 2017
2018 and what we found from the
collaborators is that they learned how
to just quantify yield in a bu much
better way than they had in the past
starting at the spring time point with
fruitfulness and they learned how to do
pruning weights and Vine balance
measures that they never did before they
kind of heard about them and they' be
like ah I don't need to do those they
actually found how to use them
effectively um they observed greater
yield quality U potential they thought
they thought for sure oh we could never
over we could never leave a full crop
these Vines will start to decline we'll
have to add more nutrition more water
that's not the case the you could
actually see no visual effect from a
Vineyard that had full crop for the last
10 years you could walk in the vineyard
and not see a difference most of them
said that they were starting to increase
their yields beyond the project to about
uh half to one ton per acre and the
biggest thing or the last two they said
they decreased the costs of goods sold
basically increased their revenue and
that's when they started doing this in
more areas of their Vineyard and they
said well we couldn't believe we used a
crop thin our value wine so heavily what
was the point now we have more of the
value wine which actually makes us all
the money and I said so you're only
doing this in the value because you
value brand because you think you can
they're like no we just have more
flexibility they said we think we can do
it in our Reserve blocks too so that was
kind of
interesting and the industry survey when
we ask them you know what are your
contracts based on and this is about the
midpoint here again yield Target bricks
disease threshold I mean to me that's a
yes no you either have it or you don't
and but it's mostly the yield Target and
bricks that is going to and method of
harvest this is what changed it was
pretty much 100% hand Harvest now they
do mechanical Harvest what we found is
that 90% still crop th but they're
starting to crop thin at higher uh
higher Target yield targets so there's
much more flexibility to negotiate what
that is whereas before it was just no
it's going to be two tons that's all I
want I don't want any more per acre um
and so greater Freedom there and a lot
of we have a lot of Vineyard management
companies and they said now they're part
of that discussion because they know the
vineyard and before it was just oh the
wine maker told them the client told
them what it had to be and then of
course U more of them are understanding
how to quantify Vine balance and are
starting to look at their Vineyard and
basically some of them are who are just
Growers are starting to arm themselves
with evidence that no we can handle more
and this is how I know whereas before
they were just like well what do I do
the buyer says they dropped more fruit
but I think it's beautiful and it's only
a week from Harvest what point is it you
know so they're having more flexibility
there and the greatest thing is that
Oregon keeps yield data and I can see
since the start of the project we have
increased yield now there's some blips
here because this was a year where we
had very very low fruit Set uh but
basically that not withstanding those
low fruit set years we basically have
increased yield by about
40 30% so three uh it's now at 2.75 tons
per acre on average for pan noore but we
know that it goes upwards of three three
three and a half tons per acre and so
and we know that this doesn't include
all companies they don't all fill out
that survey for the census but we try to
get most of them in
there so summary overall you know we
found that site and year are the most
impactful in quality and cluster
thinning cannot be used says a catch all
to make quality wine if you've got a
good site you've got a good site if you
got a bad site you've got a bad site um
and even with uh cluster thinning I take
it to one you know the if you've got a
really great site that's a reserve site
once you want more of that fruit because
you can't replicate that site and so
some Growers have gone that far they say
Okay I want more of my reserved fruit
why am I throwing it on the ground
whereas some Growers take it as well you
know I don't want to dilute that
reserved fruit I'm just going to keep
cluster thinning it the way I am but
those who have said oh I can sell more
cases of this quality wine they've done
that because they can't replicate that
that really great site but crop liting
won't make a a really bad site or poor
decision in development uh better we
also found that either bricks or pH and
anthos are the most commonly affected by
thinning but it's not Universal you are
not guaranteed to increase all of them
in any one year or to impact all of them
in anyone's site or year so it all
depends on what is that season giving
you and being in tune with that we do
know one thing high density Vineyards
are costing more than we ever thought uh
because it just it's not worth it now
you have more crop plants per acre more
cost to thin and now you pretty much
have to thin it in the high Vigor high
density
sites and that's been um also commented
on by Growers who manage on mixture of
sites they've said they've observed the
same thing since me talking about this
study um there's very limited if no wine
impact uh sensory impact when you
propped in so that was really the thing
that was very challenging for people to
swallow because they had been doing this
for so long and they see it as a risk to
how they will uh manage in the future
and there's no clear link between
thinning and wine preference over and
over again we've not been able to find
that
and I'm just trying to get Growers to
focus more on that shoot thinning aspect
and less on the late season cluster
thinning because if you've done your job
right early season you're going to be
set up much better for the whole season
you don't have to worry so much about
hitting a Target yield but if you do do
it in pounds per foot and keep in mind
the overall growth and vigor of the
vineyard rather than just tons per acre
because that's really the most important
aspect to it and then I just want to uh
accomplish uh say who are
acknowledgements here because of the
10year study how do I accomplish this
well it was piecing together uh
different funding sources I not anyone
company wanted or not anyone's uh
granting agency wanted to provide 10
years of of funding but I was able to
piece it together with my own extension
program and uh these three granting
agencies and the people I have listed
here as overtime it's not how many
people have in lab my lab right now so a
lot of people who came through my lab
over the last 12 years we're exposed to
this study in some way uh usually in in
hurting cats to get data from Growers or
get samples picked up or doing the
analysis in the lab so that I never once
put a graduate student on this because
it was too difficult to do uh but that's
that's all the people that have been
involved so hopefully I didn't go too
much over my
time all right so we have a few minutes
uh for questions does anyone here in the
room have a question I have a question
yeah so I think I saw some of your data
from first maybe a couple of years this
when I was in Oregon and it sounds like
after 10 years it just more so confirmed
everything beginning right that's yes
the question so the question was from
Dwayne who said that he observed the
first couple of years when I was sharing
this because I didn't wait for 10 years
to share this I shared it along the way
and that's why people started adopting
it along the way but basically we found
in the early years that there were no
differences and we always would hear
well you know you need that other warm
year we need we need another 2011 that's
cool and it's like hey I don't make the
weather you know that's why we do it
over 10 years and but we stayed
consistent and how we did it and that
was what I said let's stay the course
and and that's basically showed for many
okay that's enough data to support that
this is just
not necessary and I go back to well this
is why because we're already doing crop
management with our our shoot thinning
practices and so that explains and I
think people understand it more now from
that standpoint because if we were to
design it differently like spur prune
and go to 10 shoots per linear foot then
we'd be looking at a completely
different story but we're working within
the operating parameters of most
Vineyards in the in the area so yeah
that's the takeaway is that we're
already doing cluster dinning we don't
have to do it late season
but yeah there's not a lot of impact on
the fruit quality so you don't need to
plant more Acres you can just produce
more per unit land yeah great so Patty
what what's the origin of of the crop
load spinning in the industry right I
mean did they take it from another
growing region and thought it applied to
them like why do they start this
practice if they weren't observing
something that they thought was a
benefit to them 10 years ago so great
question so the question was uh where
did this practice and the kind of Target
healed come from so I asked GRS you know
they all always will try to emulate
Burgundy France where there's
restrictions but usually their
restrictions aren't on a per tons tons
per acre basis so then I started asking
the industry I said so why why two tons
why two and a half tons and they their
answer was well we can't control the
heat that we get in a year we can't
control when the rains come so the one
thing we can control is cutting fruit
off the plant they said okay fair enough
and and to them that was just creating
some consistency over time but when I
went back and calculated the amount that
they could possibly grow in the pre-1990
period two to two and a half tons per
acre is all they could grow and so that
made sense they didn't start crop
thinning until they started going to
higher densities and so one of the very
influential Growers of the region he
started planting a lot of high density
borrowing from the French and he
basically said well if we could grow
good wines at U low density at two to
two and a half tons per acre we should
keep our yield targets the same but now
have smaller
plants which didn't really add up in my
mind and so it was like that then you
just have a lot more plants per acre for
no reason essentially you have a lot
more work and so that that just kind of
stuck and then people just would you
know well we need this crop level if we
go over we will not ripen so there was a
lot of thought that over cropping would
occur and then you would not get a uh
ripe number one and number two you would
have all these growth problems the next
year and that came from a little bit of
that came from my predecessor who worked
on carbohydrates but I think it was
never clarified in the context of what
they do so in terms of they're already
shoing they're already doing all these
practices so they're not again they're
not they're regulating crop by way of
their shoot thinning early on so I think
they dis they they lost sight of what
the goal was and they just kept that
consistent cropping level and it's
pretty you can see it in the data that
they were going going along they said
that's what we have to do and I still
get Growers calling me and saying well
we have to do that and I was like
actually you don't here's this data and
so and and I'm trying to get more of it
open access and online so people Beyond
just those who have gone with us in the
story for the last 10 years years can
can learn but it's it's going against
kind of industry practice and the status
quo which can be very challenging when
that was how you achieved quality and
it's in the contracts so we've got time
for probably one more question but let
me check in with online uh Thomas BK
you've got your hand up do you have a
question yeah so first of all thanks for
a really great thorough exploration of
this mystery I've wondered about it for
many minutes many years um so wonderful
work there
um I once visited the wamt valley in mid
September penino Harvest was on here I
visited some Vineyards and raisin was
just beginning so I was thinking ypes
how are these going to ripen there's so
little season left um does the late
ripening play a role in limiting what
what the yield can be I mean town still
doesn't seem very much considering how
much sunlight you have in the
season so that if you were there and
verison was just starting in September
it probably was
2011 because 2011 was a late season uh
we usually go through start V on in
August depends on early to mid August
and so usually if the rains hold off
we're harvesting in mid September to
early October okay and so we usually do
have enough time to get the fruit ripe
um and especially in recent years now
there's always a year in there that's
like 2011 was before we started this
project but I had other projects in we
struggled to get to 22 bricks we're at
21 bricks and it was the October 20th so
everything was later that year but that
was a great year I wish we would have
had people trying that because we did
crop thinning quite severely in our on
our trials and we found that going
Beyond about four tons did nothing so it
started at the highest was seven tons we
went down to four tons and then two and
a half tons and there was no difference
between the two and a half tons and the
four tons so it was basically
um it you still could have more yield
even in that year and reached the max
Bricks now that one thing that's come
about in all of this is I think
physiologically the plant needs at least
one cluster per shoot because once you
go to less than one cluster per shoot it
gets lazy there's no not as much pull
there so the resources aren't moving to
the fruit and um we see that so
basically if you go below one cluster
Pur shoot there's no benefit and Growers
would say that too they said we would
never cluster thin the one Z one0 we
just did it for the sake of the project
so thank you everyone online too thank
thank
you this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at
cornell.edu